Welcome to Module Seven — generative adversarial networks.
The whole idea is a game between two networks.
We'll cover that game, the DCGAN recipe, mode collapse, the Wasserstein fix, and how to evaluate a generator.
Here's the setup.
A generator maps random noise to a fake image.
A discriminator tries to tell real from fake.
You train the discriminator to catch the generator, and the generator to fool the discriminator.
At the theoretical equilibrium the discriminator is reduced to guessing — fifty-fifty everywhere — but in practice that balance is famously fragile.
DCGAN was the first reliably stable recipe: transposed convolutions in the generator, strided convolutions in the discriminator, batch norm in both, LeakyReLU, no fully-connected layers, a tanh output — and Adam with beta-one turned down to zero point five.
The classic failure is mode collapse, where the generator gives up and produces only a few samples.
Watch for low diversity, and fight it with mini-batch discrimination, feature matching, or an unrolled discriminator that the generator can't game.
The bigger leap was Wasserstein GAN.
Swap the Jensen–Shannon divergence for Earth-Mover distance, rename the discriminator a critic with a linear output, and enforce a one-Lipschitz constraint — these days with a gradient penalty.
The payoff is huge: the loss finally correlates with sample quality.
You'll also want control.
Concatenate a class embedding to the noise for a conditional GAN; AC-GAN adds an auxiliary classifier; and pix2pix and CycleGAN take it all the way to image-to-image translation.
Finally, measurement.
The Inception Score rewards confident, diverse samples but is gameable.
FID — the Fréchet distance between real and generated feature statistics — is the standard, where lower is better.
Always report both, with your sample size.
Let's train a DCGAN on MNIST — open the labs.